a former chief in the nypd is accusing
the department of creating a glass
ceiling for women on the force
lori pollock filed a federal gender
discrimination lawsuit monday
it alleges quote intolerable difficult
and unpleasant working conditions that
prevent
women from advancing to the most
prestigious executive positions within
the nypd
we spoke with pollock and also learned
it's a national issue
to rise to the level that i did
only to be stopped because of my gender
is enraging
lori pollock was a three-star chief who
served the new york city police
department for 33 years
she says she was forced into retirement
last week
she's one of just five women to achieve
that high of a rank
on the force i saw other women
getting treated poorly and i knew that i
was
not going to advance not under
commissioner shea and so i i had to
leave
she alleges in a federal lawsuit that
commissioner dermot
shea denied her a promotion because of
her gender
and moved her to another position which
she considered a demotion
he ignored my request to be considered
for chief of detectives
and he subjugated me under a civilian
mail that started
the week before i was demoted hollett
claims the department has systematically
denied female
officers the opportunity to compete for
high-ranking positions
there's never been a female chief of
detectives chief of patrol
chief of department and no female police
commissioners
she's suing for monetary compensation
for the extreme stress
humiliation embarrassment mental anguish
and damage to her reputation
i think they know it's a problem but
they're not willing to address it and
that's why i have to expose it
so that something gets done about it two
former female police chiefs filed
similar lawsuits last year against the
nypd claiming they were pushed out of
their positions because of what they
call
discrimination based on age gender and
race
nationwide women make up 12 percent of
the police force
and 3 percent of local police chiefs
it's just a male dominated field
and the biases come come out when you
have men making most of the decisions
heather taylor's a near 20-year veteran
of the saint louis metropolitan police
department
and is the first female sergeant in her
department's homicide unit
she says gender bias is an issue in
departments across the country
is there a systemic gender bias in the
st louis metropolitan police department
absolutely i have young women who've
applied for jobs and
and they're qualified and the job goes
to a male
who doesn't have the degree and the
certification that
the female officer has in the time on
my friends who are all around the
country we have the same complaints
same stories same stories across racial
lines as well
the st louis metropolitan police
department denies
any gender bias and told us that 16
percent of their department is made up
of female
officers and 20 percent hold the rank of
sergeant
and above it was a great job pollock
hopes her lawsuit will bring
positive change i'd say my police career
is over
but there are so many talented women
behind me and
i feel that i need to move the ball down
the field
for those women coming in behind me the
nypd denied similar allegations of
gender discrimination in the lawsuits
filed last year
characterizing those claims as baseless
and says staff changes were based on
merit the nypd told us that they will
review miss pollock's lawsuit when
they've been served
and added that the contributions of
women both in leadership roles
and in their representation in the
uniformed and civilian ranks
across the police department cannot be
overestimated
can't be overestimated but they're
under-represented clearly
and as we you pointed out laurie pollock
has 33 years
33 years on the force how do you argue
with that
all right thanks michelle